bonjour mesdames messieurs
un bonheur de voyager avec vous dans le
monde des robots en milieu humain les
roubaud sortent des laboratoires et
envahissent les hôpitaux les entreprises
les usines et même vos domiciles
ces robots vivent dans le monde 4.0 le
3.0 vous connaissez déjà
c'est l'internet des objets le 2.0 vous
y est c'est les réseaux sociaux le 1.0
est presque dépassé celle des sites web
ces robots robot conducteur robot
médecin robot compagnon
je vous propose un voyage avec eux
première étape
partons avec les robots conducteur les
constructeurs automobiles lance sur les
routes des voitures autonome véritables
robots à quatre roues sans aucun cadre
juridique très particulier et pourtant
qu'à l'impact me direz vous l'imaginez
imaginé une cour d'assises
vous êtes le jury un jury tétanisés par
les enjeux technologiques à la barre
l'officier de police judiciaire présente
des lieux du drame
une voiture à sur un tronçon de 10 km
encastré dans la montagne
deux voies séparées par une ligne
blanche la voiture a descend normalement
dans l'habitacle une seule personne
le conducteur alors arrive au km 7 une
voiture à toute vitesse
alors que remonte une autre voiture une
voiture c'est sans conducteur dans
l'habitacle personnes les deux voitures
sont face à face la collision est
inévitable
et pourtant la voiture c'est va se
déporter
fracassé la voiture a avec une violence
inouïe
le conducteur n'a aucune chance une
enquête va montrer que l'ordinateur de
bord à d'un clic deux roues organisé la
rencontre mortels la caméra avant a vu
quatre personnes dans la voiture b une
personne dans la voiture a alors
l'algorithme celui qui existe
aujourd'hui
l'algorithme concentré d'intelligence
artificielle confondant jeu d'échecs et
circulation routière décida de sacrifier
la voiture humaine à chaque juré dans sa
tête pense 4 contre 1 et dans ce silence
mathématiques le président reprend la
parole pose la question et qui est
responsable
qui est responsable amer qui a ordonné à
la voiture d'aller chercher des enfants
le père peut-être le père qui est
propriétaire mais qui était absent au
moment des faits le vendeur d'une
voiture aussi singulière qui porte une
marque vous les connaissez ou alors le
concepteur de l'algorithme concentré
d'intelligence artificielle pour aider
le jury a décidé il appelle l'expert
judiciaire en robotique pour nous
éclairer cet expert commence par cette
situation dramatique ne peut pas exister
dans le monde
4.0 le monde des robots parce que les
hommes sont trop lents dans leurs
capacités fonctionnelles
il n'aurait pas eu la possibilité de
voir quatre personnes une personne est
d'arbitrer en temps quasi réel la
révolution robotique d'aujourd'hui est
la combinaison de deux technologies la
première les capteurs hyper performant
supérieure à l'homme la deuxième
technologie l'intelligence artificielle
embarquer ces nouveaux capteurs
permettent aux robots de prendre la
mesure de leur environnement les
informations acquises
par les capteurs sont transmises à la
plate forme d'intelligence artificielle
en temps réel alors après les espoirs
des années 80 et les désillusions des
années 90 j'étais aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle permet de
doter les robots d'une pensée primitive
sans aucun cadre juridique l'avocat des
parties civiles et l'avocat général
soutiennent la même thèse le coupable
est celui qui a écrit le clic mortels le
meurtrier est celui qui a codé
l'algorithme il a programmé une peine de
mort privé alors que dans ce cadre là il
y avait pas d'autre solution que
peut-être l'intimité du rédacteur du
code mais alors l'avocat de la défense
prend la parole et dit non non coupable
et sachant que bien évidemment une telle
position était agressive
il se tourne vers le banc des accusés et
il leur dit vous n'êtes pas coupable
et puis se tourner vers la partie civile
il ajoute madame je respecte votre
chagrin mais l'écriture du code
informatique n'est pas l'écriture de la
loi en l'absence d'un texte particulier
visant cette situation ils sont
innocents
c'est un accident verdict acquittement
c'est un futur procès qui au delà du
caractère anxiogène de la robotique
dissimule le statut juridique des
algorithmes personne ne contrôle la
voiture c'est autonome comme personne
aujourd'hui nous
entre aulnay le gardien de la google
cars qui circulent sur les routes
américaines en toute liberté au terme de
cette étape je vous propose d'aller avec
les robes aux médecins ce sera peut-être
moins dramatique
vous pouvez rêver
les robots pullulent dans les hôpitaux
des laboratoires d'analysés médicales à
la plateforme chirurgicale ils sont
partout les robots actifs commencent à
remplacer les robots passif ce qui sont
téléopéré les robots aujourd'hui at il
opère de bout en bout
certaines pathologies le chirurgien est
reléguée aux phases de préparation et
deux supervision observé un hôpital
service des urgences une femme elle
entre pour un diagnostic du cancer à
l'accueil on écoute la fermière de
dispatching lui propose
voulez-vous un rendez vous avec un
médecin ou un robot énervée elle répond
un humain couloir 2 madame porte cette
mauvais choix très mauvais choix couloir
watson consulte watson c'est l'avatar du
bm le champion qui a battu les meilleurs
au jus jeopardy et qui aujourd'hui est
capable de diagnostic supérieur dans
certains domaines à des grands
professeurs la supériorité de watson
robot très particulier est incapable
d'entrer dans le droit médical
alors je suis d'accord avec vous
l'erreur humaine n'est pas équivalente à
l'erreur robot ça n'a pas de sens mais
soumettent les robots aux droits des
objets c'est aussi un non sens comment
admettre que l'erreur robot d'un robot
qui est supérieur à ses collègues
médecins puissent être traitées par un
défaut d'une machine j'arrive au terme
de ce second voyage et pour cette
nouvelle espèce d'être artificiel il
faudra nécessairement réguler la liberté
des robots comme on à réguler la liberté
des hommes les personnes physiques ont
une personnalité juridique
droit de propriété droit à l'identité
droit la personnalité les personnes
morales telles que les entreprises ont
une personnalité juridique certes avec
des adaptations nécessaires
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité eh
bien c'est la fermeture de la société
alors dans ce cadre la personne physique
personnalité juridique général personne
morale personnalité juridique
particulière personnes robot lançons le
terme personnalité juridique singulière
dans ce monde 4.0 des robots les robots
son sujet et non pas objet de droit
dernier élément de ce parcours examinons
la personnalité juridique à travers ses
singularités que sont la responsabilité
la traçabilité et la dignité
l'enjeu c'est la dignité la
responsabilité c'est simple en cascade
le robot responsable c'est normal il est
libre ensuite la plateforme le
responsable celui qu'il a fournie c'est
elle qui a permis le soc de cette
liberté en deuxième
l'utilisateur parce que c'est lui qui a
défini les conditions d'utilisation et
d'apprentissage
oui les robots pense quelque part et
puis le système classique
la traçabilité des hommes c'est
impossible
on est libre et on n'a pas le droit de
suivre ni notre identité ni nos
activités sauf cas particulier pour les
robots ça doit être différent bien
évidemment les robots doivent décliner
leur identité
les robots c'est un nouveau genre sommes
à deux femmes trois robots alors c'est
sur le terrain de la dignité que se fait
la différence
la dignité des robots oui c'est
important la dignité des robots regardez
c'est une petite poupée elle parlait le
dialogue avec une enfant et toutes ces
données sont envoyées aux états unis
pour pouvoir être apprécié cette
intimité revient par des réponses
affiner mais aussi un encerclement
informationnel l'enfant va être guidé
dans ses désirs à travers
réponse et la politique marketing voilà
où nous en sommes now un autre robot
il y attend d'intimité dans un enfant
autiste qui revient à la vie ou une
personne âgée qui reprend le goût de
rire en dialoguant avec now now a été
pensée design by éthiques
on peut espérer et au terme de ce voyage
l'année 2015 marque l'avènement d'un
nouveau monde peuplé de robots
je propose de leur reconnaître la
personnalité juridique
conjuguant vie robotique et vies
humaines ou responsabilité traçabilité
dignité du robot formeront le socle du
droit des robots créés ont eu ensemble
c'est cela la nouvelle vie avec les
robots